Latin America is home to the largest
number of Roman Catholics but the flock
is dwindling as dramatically is the
church's influence revelations of
widespread clerical sex abuses are
greatly to blame but they're not the
only reason
Beatriz for Kara and former priest Luis
Pena are newlyweds Luis took his vows of
chastity at age 17 but ten years ago he
fell in love with Beatriz they kept the
relationship secret but although he
loved his pastoral work he says he
couldn't keep living a double life so he
left the priesthood last year if I could
have been married and remained a priest
I would have been overjoyed but it
wasn't possible I wish that would change
because I believe it's completely
compatible to devote oneself to a family
and also to pastoral work at least I
don't excel in decisive Luis was an
excellent priest he was very close to
everyone young and old the parish loved
him so it was hard
now the Catholic Church's rigid
disciplinary norm that demands celibacy
from priests could be changed or at
least loosened starting in the Amazon
which is shared by nine South American
countries during the Amazon Synod of
Bishops last October there was consensus
that the Catholic Church desperately
needs more priests not only for the sake
of souls but also to save the Amazon
rainforest from deforestation which has
been one of the Pope's key focuses and
in order to get more priests it was
argued that it might be necessary to end
the prohibition on marriage the idea is
being resisted by the Vatican's most
Orthodox wing with the blessing of
former Pope Benedict a controversial new
book by Cardinal Robert Serra argues
that lifting the celibacy law would
strongly damage the Catholic Church the
world's oldest institution but others
insist that enforcing the celibacy law
is discouraging priests from joining and
damaging the reputation of those who've
already taken their vows one of them is
father Antonia de la Fuente who believes
that making an exception for the Amazon
region is not the answer I don't think
that this reform should apply to one
specific case whether there should be a
profound study carried out about the
celibacy requisite and the decision that
results from it should apply to the
entire Catholic Church not just a
segment of it still the Vatican has
defended celibacy for more than a
thousand years and given its historic
aversion to reforms abolishing it could
take a long time we see in human al
Jazeera Santiago